wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only dr miles monroe
that is the wealthiest spot on this
planet
is not
the diamond mines of south africa
it's not the oil fields of iran or iraq
it's not the
uranium mines of the soviet union it's
it's not the
the oil wells of iraq
the wealthiest spot on this planet is
not the
sea
food of the oceans
but the wealthiest spot on this planet
is right in your neighborhood
it's the cemetery
if i could mine the cemetery like you
mine gold i would be the wealthiest man
on the planet
why is the graveyard so wealthy why is
there so much treasure in the cemetery
why because buried in the cemetery are
dreams that were never fulfilled
books that were never written
ideas that never became reality visions
that were never manifested there in the
graveyard are paintings that were never
painted songs that were never written
books that we'll never read in the
cemetery are great manufacturing plants
that were never built
in the cemetery are sermons that were
never preached
the cemetery is pregnant with unused
success
buried in the cemetery
is treasure
that makes god
weep
my greatest fear tonight is very simple
and that is i am afraid that most of you
in this room and in this auditorium
tonight and perhaps watching this
program you are going to add to the
treasure and the wealth of the cemetery
and that makes me very sad
because buried inside of you are dreams
that you still carry
ideas that god planted in your heart
that you still haven't done yet
paintings that you've been planning to
paint and books you've been thinking
about writing and paintings you keep
procrastinating about
and what i'm so concerned about is we'll
never see your painting
we'll never sing a song we'll never read
your book and we'll never
operate in your business and we'll never
experience the invention that you keep
procrastinating on
i trust that you will rob the graveyard
of your treasure yes
i pray that you will disappoint the
cemetery
i pray that when the the mall gets your
carcass it'll be empty
treasure
what do you call this
massive treasure
that's in every
cemetery it's called
potential
write the word down
potential everybody say it
potential say one more time potential
why is this called potential
well potential i want to define it for
you one more time potential is untapped
power
potential is unused ability
are you ready
potential is dormant
strength
potential is hidden power
potential is all you could be but you
haven't become yet
potential is how far you can go in life
but you haven't gone yet
potential is who you really are but we
haven't seen you yet
potential is everything you could be but
you haven't become it yet potential
is all you can do but you haven't done
yet
in essence potential is never what
you've done please make a note of that
potential is never what you've done it's
always what you could do but you haven't
done yet
in essence whenever you've done
something it's no longer your potential
therefore
potential
is everything that is yet
unused
that is still within you
i am convinced that god has buried in
every human being all 5.2 billion of us
treasure
that is yet to be tapped
let's put it this way
if potential
is not what you've done but what you
could do
then whatever you've done is no longer
your potential therefore you should
never be impressed by what you've done
because if you are impressed by what
you've done is stop you from doing what
you could do
the greatest enemy of progress is your
last success
the greatest threat
to moving ahead is getting excited about
where you are
[Music]
whenever you feel like what you've done
is the best you could do you just died
[Music]
no matter what you've done if it didn't
kill you
there's more left
as long as you're breathing god got
something else left inside until you are
gone you're still pregnant
because god sent you here and no human
being came to this planet empty
i repeat
no human
came to this planet empty
you came here loaded and you came here
to make a deposit and deposit you will
make and if you don't make you are a
generational thief because you stole
from the next generation
the next generation supposed to benefit
from what you came to deliver and if you
settle down on what you've done and not
do what you could do then you rob them
of what you came to leave for them to
enjoy
and that is why you should never allow
what you've done to stop you from doing
what you could do no matter how great
what you've done is don't park
tell your neighbor i feel my baby moving
now
i want to
[Music]
talk to you about
the best kept secret
and the best kept secret
is a strange secret
because only one person has it
and the secret is about you
there's a secret about you
that nobody knows
except the one who manufactured you
there's information on you that has been
kept
because
if it was ever given to anybody else
they won't believe it
first i want to deal with a little issue
before i go any further i want to talk
about
how
to be set free
so you can discover your secret
the key to freedom
is knowledge
just write these principles down
the key to freedom is knowledge
and the key to knowledge
is
truth
the key to knowledge is truth
and
the key to truth
is the manufacturer
i repeat there's a principle the key to
truth is the manufacturer
let's talk
the greatest enemy of man is not
sin
the greatest enemy of man is not satan
the greatest enemy of man
is ignorance
ignorance is the cause of all
destruction
as a matter of fact we blame so many
things on this
entity that we call devil
that we've become irresponsible lately
we eat bad get sick and then blame it on
the devil
ignorance is
the major enemy of man
god says
my people perish
or they are destroyed
because of a lack
of
knowledge
and because they have rejected knowledge
i must also reject them and they cannot
represent me
and then he goes one step further he
says and i must also reject their
children
here's the point if you don't know
anything
and you teach your children what you
know
then your children is as smart as you
write this down all i know is what i've
learned
say with me
all i know
is what i have learned one more time all
i know is what i've learned now you got
to let that sink in for a minute
no matter how many books you bought you
only know the ones you read
don't look now if someone's looking at
you
some of you bought books last year and
haven't cracked the pages yet
and you show people your library and try
and impress them in what you don't know
[Applause]
you've brought videotapes and haven't
burst the plastic on it yet you bought
cassette tapes and haven't listened to
them yet you see buying information
doesn't give you revelation
[Applause]
here's what god says about that he says
because you have rejected knowledge
i must reject you it's impossible to
reject something that was not available
therefore your ignorance was a decision
half now
90
of the knowledge you need is right in
your house in a book you never read
that's good
every time you pass a library knowledge
incriminates you
god says
you are perishing because you lack
knowledge so don't blame it on the devil
don't blame it on your mother-in-law
don't blame it on your teacher don't
blame it on the school system
you don't need a teacher to learn
oh come on say something minnesota
some of you are blamed it on the
education department
you don't need a professor to make you
read a book
i'll never forget the day when i
walked on the premises of the university
i attended
i walked into my first class freshman
and here comes this professor
and i was so excited all my books and i
sat there ready
eager to learn
and i saw this great bank of reservoir
of knowledge walk into the room and i
said to myself i'm gonna learn so much
from this great man
and he stood there for five minutes and
says good morning
i'm glad that you are here today
our course of study shall last for this
semester
you have five books to read
tonight i want you to take the first
book read the first five chapters write
a paper i'll see you tomorrow
where you going
i just paid two thousand dollars to come
to this school come back here preacher
and he left
and i got mad
and i said wait a minute i just paid two
thousand dollar tuition and another
sixteen hundred dollars for for room and
board and i bought all these books for
hundreds of dollars and the man spent
five minutes in the class
i went to the library
and realized that
i was going to be spending over 57 000
for someone to tell me go and read a
book
come on clap you know it's true
[Applause]
knowledge is
the key
to freedom
[Music]
but the key
to knowledge
got to be checked carefully
i used to think that knowledge
[Music]
was power
that's not necessarily true
because you can learn the wrong thing
[Music]
jesus said the only thing that can set
you free is not knowledge
but knowledge of the
truth
it's dangerous to learn the wrong thing
well
some people are experts in error
come on talk to me
so knowledge doesn't mean you're smart
because what you may have learned may
not be true
and the most dangerous thing for a
person to have
is knowledge that is erroneous that they
believe is true
the most dangerous human being i've ever
met is one who has zealots error
people with zeal who are wrong
and it's the cause of great tragedy in
our humanity and in our history of man
most of the problems in our past are
results of zealous erroneous people
people who had information that was
erroneous it was wrong but they thought
it was right and they were zealous
hitler for example believed that
everybody else was sub-human and the
aryan race was the only true human race
and that era made him massacre millions
of people
the crusaders who were christians
were under an era and they killed
thousands and thousands of people all
over europe because they had a
theological error and tried to force
people to come to jesus with the sword
and then you
used to preach against speaking in
tongues and you used to rebuke people
who did it and now you're doing it more
than they
don't look at me so funny some of you
used to have scriptures to prove it was
from the devil
look at you now
it's amazing what we do with era
we defend it vehemently
that's why jesus said knowledge of the
truth
shall set you free not just knowledge
but the truth
now i mentioned to you that truth the
key to truth is who the manufacturer
what do i mean by that
the manufacturer is the only one who
knows the truth about his product
[Music]
let me try one more time
the manufacturer is the only one
who knows the truth
about his product
everybody else is experimenting
everybody else is guessing
and everybody else has opinions
the manufacturer knows the truth about
his product that's why you shouldn't get
information from anyone else except the
manufacturer don't even believe the
retailer because he's in business for
sales
[Applause]
oh it helped me tonight
that's why i don't trust humans
[Music]
to tell me who i am
[Applause]
don't depend on customers experience
to determine the value of a product
because some customers don't know how to
use it
you all are slow here tonight
many of us have literally allowed people
to talk us out of good products
because they abused it
and it didn't work for them
not because your marriage didn't work
does it mean marriage doesn't work
[Applause]
hello
[Applause]
you just didn't know how to stay married
you didn't follow the manufacturer's
manual you didn't follow the
specifications
hello somebody
so if the toaster didn't work for you
that doesn't mean the toaster ain't no
good
you just plugged it in wrong
are you understanding me the truth about
a product is only hid in the mind of the
manufacturer there's some things that
you can do
that are based on the kingdom system
that will give you the success
and the prosperity that you need in the
midst of that crisis
a couple of things about crisis to write
down number one crisis
is to incubate our creativity
most of the time we're not a creative
until something bad happens to us
when things fall apart it makes us think
outside the box
secondly
crisis demands a new way of thinking
about old problems
an old problem is you got to pay a
mortgage
the problem is
the source of income that you used to
pay it with has been dried up
but the old problem hasn't gone away you
still got to pay your mortgage
so what you gotta do is find a new way
to
generate income to pay the old problem
so crisis actually forces you to think
about new ways to solving old problems
thirdly crisis is an opportunity to
improve
and advance over old ideas
sometimes the only way for you to move
on is for something to happen to push
you
and many times we don't grow until we
have to
so crisis comes many times to improve us
because we've been stuck in a place too
long
and number five crisis comes also
to produce growth and it also produces a
sense of development it makes you
develop new approaches to life
crisis creates
new opportunities
it's amazing when when we uh look at the
world today every progressive invention
came out of a problem
and that's because crisis makes you
develop and think in new ways number
seven is very important crisis produces
and manifests true leadership ability
no matter how much you would like to
claim to be a leader only crisis proves
it
you are not
really a leader
in good times
anybody can lead in good times
leadership is tested and proven when
there is a crisis environment
so crisis comes to test to see if you
are as mature as you claim to be
shakespeare said these words i love it
he says sweet
are the uses
of adversity
say that with me
sweet are the uses of adversity that's a
deep statement
in other words he's telling us when
things are adverse when things are in
crisis
don't panic
use them
use them
for the positive result
everything that happens to you could be
used
to produce something good
that's amazing everything
so shakespeare caught on to something he
realized
in his own thinking
that adversity
can be used
to benefit the one under the adversity
the richest man one richest man in
america his name is john huntsman jon
huntsman is the founder of one of the
largest companies the united states and
they produce
about 90 of all the plastics forks and
spoons that you use in your house or at
your parties this company is the one
this is like the number one company in
the world that produce plastic plates
and and plastic cups this is the company
here it's owned by this man
his company fell into debt
and his company actually collapsed some
years ago
and he went into a crisis mode and he
rented a bank the bank said they loaned
no more money and his company
went into bankruptcy he went home and
told his wife i quit i'm never going to
start this company again i'm going to go
find me a job it's over
his wife said to him honey
you told me that this idea was given to
you by god and that you going to build
this and make it successful you that's
why i married you i believe you
now if you're gonna do this go back and
start again
he said his wife made him go back
and ask another bike
he left the old bank
and he showed the bike
the truth he said here's what i did
in the last 15 years here's what
happened
and i could start again i know how to
build a business will you trust me and
the bank says i'll take a chance on you
he had no credibility
no
assets
just a record that he built the company
the bank took a chance on him
and he began to start the company again
today the company is worth over 14
billion dollars
he ran for the president united states
during the time of obama you remember
this man's name he's one of the
candidates for the president of the
united states
billionaire here's what he said as a
result of his crisis i quote
if there is a silver lining
to bad times
it is this
when facing severe challenges your mind
is normally at its sharpest
end quote
now look at the statements
in that statement
he said when you are under the biggest
pressure
that is when your mind is normally at
its sharpest
because your mind is having to think of
things you never thought of before see
the problem with humanity is we are
creatures of habit
we have a habit of going to work
and all of a sudden you ain't got no
work you're still going to work
there are folks who get to put their
clothes on for god they got fired
[Applause]
and they drive past the place up and
down and just look at the place hey you
are fired okay
break the pattern
[Applause]
we got a pattern of being broke
so we even get money be spending just to
make sure we are broke
[Applause]
it's a pattern but crisis comes to break
the pattern write this down crisis
initiates new concepts it also renews
our vision it cancels experience this
one is important when a crisis comes
your experience becomes useless
this is why the most silent voices today
are the economists
they are saying nothing right now for
the last five years the economists have
said nothing they've made no
recommendations you know why every
principle they ever taught them in
school
has been cancelled
the economy that is now existing
never existed before they never saw a
country
become bankrupt
they never saw a failed government
before what do you do when nothing you
learned is working
a crisis comes to cancel that
and that this is why i think you know
i've been taught like many of you my
parents were so nice they said children
go to school get an education
and then they would say
experience is the best teacher
well that's not always true
experience could be your worst enemy
because if you got experience
in doing something a certain way
and the environment changed
your experience becomes your enemy
well i never had to do this certain job
before yeah but you broke now you better
learn to do it
but i got a lot of experience in banking
yeah but in a bike iron right now you
got to go work in the hotel
i got an experience in hotel yeah but
hotels ain't higher and you better learn
to be a gardener
come on look at me that way see your
experience is destroyed by crisis
sometimes we become so hooked on our
experience
we wait until we find something that can
use our experience and nothing wants
your experience
you have to almost retool yourself
sometimes you got to relearn things you
gotta you gotta learn new skills why
because life has a way of shaking things
loose
there are people right now who are so
proud they are starving
i can't to get that job that's below me
oh yeah
you you better get that job take that
job that's available we're gonna soon
bury you below the ground if you don't
get your act together and put your pride
in your pocket
[Applause]
if a job opens up tell them i'm going to
take it
for a season i tell our young people i
say to you right now stop looking for
employment
why don't you position yourself
differently and look for deployment
to employers to be employed means that
somebody else is benefiting from your
energy
to deploy me to deploy yourself means
that you are using your own energy to be
productive
instead of waiting for someone to give
you a job create your own work
that's why i tell people that's
different between their work and your
job
your job is what they train you to do
your work is what you were born to do
your job is your skill which they can
fire you from that in time but your work
is your gift no one can take that from
you
your job is where you get compensation
for activity
your work is where you get fulfillment
because you love it so much
your job you can retire from your work
you can never retire from your work
because your work is you
so when a person discovers their work
they no longer need a job because their
work makes them productive so there are
young people in this country who are
full of talents full of gifts
and i want to say this too
every problem in life is a business
all businesses are simply someone
solving a problem so the more problems
that are in kenya the more business is
available for young people to begin
and this is what i think we are lacking
we are trained to get a job we're not
trained to start a business
we are trained
to let other people employ us not
trained to deploy ourselves and this
even happens in governments in our
emerging countries most governments
depend on external investors for
survival of their countries how about
this how about focusing on on producing
your own end products to sell to the
investor
my perspective for example even in kenya
kenya has so much natural resources
the greatest resource in kenya is the
intelligence of its people
uh all the other natural resources
supposed to be
complementing that natural source of
intelligence
i want to encourage the
this great country uh kenya as you
celebrate 50 years to refocus your
entire
culture of development and that is focus
on not just providing natural
resource material for the world but how
about providing end products for the
world power for me to be successful was
not in the teachers it was not in the
educational system it was not in my
culture it was not in my society it was
within me and i began to think god if
you are a good god why am i poor
if you are a great god why are these
people better than me
if you make me in your image why are
they
special and i'm a monkey
and that night
no thunder no lightning no earthquakes
nothing
i just heard a voice in my mind and the
voice said
i ask you to believe me
and you will be saved not them
and that night i made a commitment to
believe what god said 13 years i said
okay i believe
that i
have the power
to experience far beyond all i can ever
ask think or imagine 13 years old and
that's when my pursuit of god began
when was it that you realized you wanted
to become a preacher
you know i didn't want to become a
preacher matter of fact today i still
consider myself a preacher
i think
it drove me to have a passion
to help everybody who's been oppressed
my passion is to make sure that no one
can should live under what i experienced
i never desired to be a a minister
i desired to help people success
is not what you've done
compared to what other people have done
sometimes we think success is a
competition
competition is a sign of insecurity
successful people have no competition
if you study them
they're not interested in what you're
doing at all
they too committed to what they do
successful people
don't compare themselves to anyone that
leads to point number two
success
is defined as
what you've done compared to what you
were created to do
in other words success and failure is
determined by
how much you fall short of what the
manufacturer designed you to perform
in other words success is competition
with yourself
let me put it another way if you knew
that you could have done better
you are a failure think about it for a
second
i remember one day when i came home from
school i was so excited
i gotta be in class and i ran home
told my mama look at my exam my test
little kid you know i was excited i got
a b and and i got 75 on the test
and i was so excited and my mother says
what are you so proud of
she said i know you boy
there's an a inside of you
go back and go study again
here i am so excited for the beach she
said no you an eight kid she was
teaching me the lesson
she said now you came first in the class
with 75.
you are still a failure
it simply means the other kids didn't
try at all
so you can always find someone less than
you that doesn't make you a success
be fruitful
okay this is where business begins the
word fruitful in hebrew means productive
it doesn't mean to have children i was
shocked when i discovered that uh the
first command god gave my hand was what
be
productive in other words produce
something
it be productive stop saying fruitful
cause you're thinking about babies tell
your neighbor be productive
no say this way produce something that i
could buy
that's the first command
now here's something important to
remember
the first command is to be what fruitful
the first command should have been
be seedful
because fruit
is a result of seed
you can't have fruit unless you have a
seed that has a tree that bear fruit
god ignores the entire first step
look at me man let's get deep now
god say look i even ain't going to talk
about seed
oh you still didn't get it listen when
god
demands something from you
it exists
so the demand for fruit
is a presumption
that there is seed somewhere the number
one reason why there's poverty
in north council
it's not because of a lack of investors
coming in but a lack of productivity
inside listen listen here's how you
measure a nation's wealth listen
carefully
a nation's wealth is measured
by three letters all nations
gross
national productivity in other words if
the nation ain't producing
they call it poor in the u.n
money doesn't make you rich productivity
does that's why china is one of the
biggest threats right now even though
they may be poor they are producing
what do most people in the north tells
to do consume
you keep going to the bank to borrow
money to buy stuff that isn't productive
i mean if you're going to buy a vehicle
buy a truck so you can become one who
collects garbage to produce a business
don't buy a car to drive around in that
ain't productive
the command
presumes
that seed exists
in you right now
there's a seed
that's your business
and god says
show me the fruit of it
produce something
now when you produce a product
watch god's strategy now let's say okay
apple computer
stephen george crisco because he had an
idea i was an idea
that's your seed
your seed is the idea that it won't grip
this guy had an idea he went to visit
a plant to see a computer
and he went and he saw this computer and
the computer was biggest half of this
room
he looked at he says why can't they
reduce that to the size of a desk
and he walked out and he kept seeing
visions
of that great massive computer the size
of a room on a desk
i wonder what you see they won't leave
you alone
write this down every problem is a
business
i'll say it again every problem is a
business
one man see bare feet that's a problem
the other one see a shoe company
that's a business
one man see a hog island
that's a problem
another man sees a resort
that's a business
produce your seed
produce your fruit
and i want to focus on discovering
and releasing how to release your hidden
greatness
every human being in this room
and those watching by the internet
you have inside of you i have no doubt
about it
greatness
but most people will die with the
greatness on the inside
and this is why we have this conference
because we don't want you to be one of
those persons who die
with their greatness let me say a few
comments about greatness
every human
desires two things in life i want you to
write them down two things every human
wants
six billion of us
and now seven billion cents last may
april
on this planet
want two things and everything you do
is motivated by these two things one we
want power
every young person every old person
wants power we gotta talk about what
power is
and the second thing we want is
greatness
we don't talk about these too much but
every human being wants power
and they want greatness this is why we
are motivated to wear
certain clothing
we call them power clothing
this is why we try to
join a gang
because being in a gang of people gives
you power to threaten other people
this is why you would actually want to
steal money or gain money because money
gives you power to buy things that you
want to make you feel important
everything we do is motivated by these
two things power and greatness
now i want to mention something about
power what is power
power
i want you to quote it with me out loud
up on the board so you can remember it
when you leave here what is power read
it power is the ability
and the capacity to control
circumstances and in the environment
that's power
power is what the ability to control
circumstances
and to control your environment
that's what power is and everybody wants
it the politician wants it
the banker wants it
the parent wants it
the young person wants it everybody
wants power to control circumstances
what is greatness write this down
greatness out loud please is a
sense of value
importance and significance that's
greatness
great is when you feel
that you are important to the world
you feel great when you feel that you
are valuable to society
greatness is when you feel that you are
significant
to your generation in other words
the desire for all of us to be great
and to control
our environment is natural
you as a 16 year old
your desire to become the head of the
class
is a desire for greatness
you as an 18 year old your desire to go
to college and get a degree so you can
get a better job so you can make more
money so you can buy things you want
it's a desire for control
a desire for greatness
and this is why people get in trouble
they're pursuing power
and greatness now let me just repeat
again the pursuit of power and greatness
is natural
as a matter of fact if you don't want to
be great something's wrong with you
if you have no desire
to be
powerful
something's wrong with you
every person here desires these things i
put it this way god is not against your
desire
for greatness he's not against your
desire for power
because god created you
to be great potential is who you are but
no one knows it yet
potential is who you could become but
you haven't become it yet potential is
how far you can go but you haven't gone
yet in other words potential is never
what you've done
because once you've done something it
ceases to be your potential
potential therefore has to do with what
you haven't done yet
that you can still yet do and that's why
i am after you i came after you because
i'm bored what you've done i'm bored
you got a phd so what it's over what's
left that's right
[Music]
potential therefore it's not about what
you've achieved it's what you haven't
achieved yet that you could achieve and
this is why i say this that the end of
your potential write it down is your
last success
the greatest enemy of your potential is
your success because when you become
successful at something it tempts you to
stop
[Music]
this is why i am always
nervous about people's accolades
concerning me
i don't trust too many awards to forgive
me
i have so many degrees to store the
funding
and i hide them away
because i don't even want to see them
they may stop me from moving
nothing is more dangerous
than counting on your
[Music]
and success you possess the potential
and it's hidden
there's some examples of character that
you need to write down now why do we
call for example the alphabet characters
because
a is always a
b
is b at 2 am in the morning
c is still c whether it's in africa
asia
or in the bronx
it doesn't change that's why we call
them characters
why do we call numbers characters
because one is always one
[Music]
and two is always two
whether you are using it in the night or
the day
it doesn't change
this character
why do we call statues characters
because like victoria no matter what
happens around them
they
never
change
why do we call principles characters
because principles are laws
they never
change
you know one of the secrets to my
success
as a
coach
of government leaders and business
leaders one of my secrets of being an
effective communicator
one of my secrets of being a good
teacher
is simple
it's not my education
the secret to my success
is i only teach
principles
that's it
you can never
disagree with the principle
you can
ignore it
you can hate it
but you can never disagree with it for
example
gravity is a principle
[Music]
you can fast and pray and speak in
tongues but if you jump of a building
you're going to die
why you are violating a principle
character is that way
that's why a person with character
does not live
on what's popular
[Music]
they live on what is principle
and this is why it's very difficult for
politicians to have character
[Music]
because politics is based on popularity
which means you will literally sacrifice
your principles
to protect your popularity which cancels
your character which means you cannot be
trusted
there are preachers who are politicians
they would sell their principles
for a pot of porridge
no character
character therefore is simply that which
is unchanging write it down uh my
question is how often do you change
who are you
are you the same person all the time
are you consistent
are you predictable
leaders
must
have character
why write this down
people
will not follow you if they don't trust
you
so character attracts
loyalty the kingdom gives
the kingdom gives
his wealth
to his citizens
to accomplish
his purposes in the colony this is a
very important statement
the kingdom and the king
the king himself he owns everything and
whatever he gives you is not for you
it's for his purposes in the colony
this is important because the moment you
think what you receive is yours
then you
lock it up
you stop it with you you hold on to it
and that is anti-kingdom
if god cannot get it
through you
he won't get it to you
anything god gives you
is to accomplish his purpose
in the quality
i remember the scripture
that explodes in my mind at the moment
deuteronomy
chapter 7 and chapter 8 are important
chapters to read is when the lord
brought them out of egypt he began to
tell them how they must think their
attitudes
and then he said to them he said
he said
i
am your god
and it is i who will give you the power
to get wealth
now that word power there means ability
or
skill
i will give you the ability the power
the skill to get wealth and the silence
ends like this so that i might
accomplish my covenant
that i made with abraham
in other words i'm going to make you
wealthy
to fulfill my covenant in the earth
so anytime the king gives you
resources
remember your first question should be
what's it for
not who it's for my definition of
leadership is very simple yet
complicated i believe that leadership is
uh the capacity to influence others
through inspiration not manipulation and
that inspiration comes from a passion
which is motivated by a sense of vision
and a sense of purpose so leadership is
very personal then it's corporate uh
leadership is not something you pursue
it's something you discover leaders are
born when a human discovers something
more important than their personal
ambition
leadership you don't pursue it
leadership is no true leaders do not
seek followers leaders actually are
pursuing a passion toward a purpose that
gives them a sense of destiny for
example one of the greatest leaders of
example that i use is nelson mandela one
of your great presidents uh he never
sought followers think about it he
discovered a purpose that was more
important than his private
preservation and private ambition he
pursued that person purpose privately it
attracted people so leaders don't seek
followers followers are attracted to
leaders leaders are more concerned about
discovering a purpose to improve the
life of humanity that's more important
than their personal ambition so they
sacrificed themselves to accomplish
something for the greater good yeah we
find that very rarely most people we
call leaders are simply professional
manipulators and they actually are more
concerned with their own promotion than
promoting the people intellectual
development you have the more spiritual
development you have the more
psychological development your emotional
stability you become more valuable to
the world and let me say this finally
if you become valuable to the world the
world will pay you to be yourself
so it's important for you to become a
person of value not to seek value in
things
i get paid for what i know not what i do
and i think this is what we need to
perceive as being most valuable uh do
you know what they actually call in
intellect they call it capital
you know international capital is really
a commodity and so uh i want to
encourage our young people to
focus on
on discovering the purpose for your life
why god created you and then discover
your gifts and then refine them develop
them practice them and then even begin
to serve them freely to your community
develop yourself and in a short time you
will discover that
people will pursue you
because when you develop your fruit and
you maximize your fruit of your gift in
life
just like a tree
trees never bring their fruit to you
that's right they just simply manifest
them you attract you are attracted to
the tree so when you develop your gifts
and refine your gifts you don't need to
look for followers they'll find you
that's right after all leadership is not
about finding followers it's about
followers being attracted to what you
have and this is true commodity
how do you think your opinions are
can we solve this leadership problem in
africa
you know the leadership problems in all
developing countries not just africa but
all of them uh really historical
problems uh and all of them result from
the same experience and that is
colonialism
oppressive colonialism in the last 300
years was not designed to produce
leaders it was designed to maintain
followers in other words the
the colonialists had no interest in
making
the oppressed leaders they wanted to
make them slaves and so there was no
need for them to train them to educate
them to prepare them for power to manage
resources and so when those colonial
powers finally
took the chains off and released these
nations uh they ended up with nations
that had a lot of resources but no
leadership training
and so much of the leaders that emerged
from post-colonial uh
uh situations were
actually leaders who were freedom
fighters
uh they had to have you know wars for
their freedom uh over the you know from
the imperialist powers so many of these
become military people or they become
jungle fighters suddenly you have a guy
who fought the military he's now a prime
minister or a president i mean this is
an amazing transition here and so how do
you come out of the jungle and become a
prime minister uh that's what most of
history is for these third world
countries i had to fight for my freedom
and now i'm the prime minister
i have no training to run a country to
manage resources to develop programs to
establish institutions and here i am in
charge of a country and so you could say
that the leadership problem in
developing countries is proof that
colonialism failed
in developing venus and i put us at the
doorstep of the colonial powers who are
still around today many of those powers
actually blame companies like africa you
know i mean england and america and you
know great britain and france they look
at africa and they go you guys can't
lead look what you've done you're
corrupt and my response is no
the the question is did you produce us
as leaders
don't blame us for our lack of
experience and development our lack of
capability and skills you didn't train
us
so i think that this this period we're
living in right now
where most of the leaders who fought for
freedom are still alive many of them are
dying we've got a few of them left this
is a whole era of what i call transition
it's it's experimentation and what we
need now is to prepare young men and
young women who are trained as leaders
no longer just products or circumstances
but who have been intentionally trained
to become leaders to to to develop the
skills and the character and the
fortitude and the understanding of
passion and vision and sensitivity and
compassion
change is one thing that is permanent in
life and yet people
are afraid of it
the only thing you can guarantee in life
is change
there's nothing as permanent or sure as
change change is actually inevitable
so if change is a constant
the key to life then is to learn how to
manage and benefit from change change is
beautiful for example
i said it's often that
there can be no
improvement
without change
and yet not all change is improvement
for example if you used to weigh 110
pounds and now you weigh 170 that was a
change
but it's not an improvement it can
actually be a threat to your health
but if you want to
improve
you have to change and god is a god of
change even though god never changes
because everything god does is always
temporary he never does the same thing
twice
no miracle in the bible was ever
repeated
god never healed anyone the same way
twice
god is too creative
to remain a constant
god is permanent but he never does
anything the same way twice
so you got to get used to change
and change is the most beautiful thing
in the world because change means that
you are never going to be bored in life
when you keep company with god and do
you know that uh we hate change because
change threatens our security
and our security is what traps us
nothing is more dangerous
to self-destruction than comfort
this is why
you know ecclesiastes 3 says this
it says to everything there's a season
then it says it's a time to be born and
a time to die
there's a time to laugh and a time to
mourn we love the laughter part
but we forget that there's going to be a
change where sometimes we got to cry
we love the part where it says we gather
whatever the prophet says we scatter
you know change comes into your life to
remind you that nothing is permanent
you got to learn therefore to live life
very loosely don't hold on to anything
too
that's why god has the principle of
change in life the danger of your
comfort and security is it traps you
from development and growth
whenever god wanted to do something
great he always upset comfort
because the only way for god to take you
where you're supposed to be
is to get you to leave where you are
and where you are
is secure
change produces two things it produces
insecurity
and the unknown and both of them are
very important for growth and
development and we are afraid because we
expect things to remain the same
like i said earlier the most important
approach to dealing with change is to
expect it
we expect things to remain the same and
so we set ourselves up for
disappointment
the way you benefit from change is you
expect it as you look back over your
life if there's just one thing that you
could do differently
what would it be
that's always that's always a tough
question i get that the question asks a
lot uh
i'm not sure you know because everything
that happened in my life
produced me
even the negatives even the things that
i might have failed in the things i've
made mistakes with they were fantastic
classrooms for me
and i believe the best thing in life to
do is not to regret and try to change
what happened
but to interpret it properly maximize it
and use it to serve other people and
that's what i want to do with my past
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want some incredible bishop td jake's
motivation check the video right there
next to me continue to believe and i'll
see you there intellect can describe it
but only instinct can find it you must
understand that the purpose is the
underlying of chemistry that makes you
live your life your kids are not going
to make you happy your spouse is not
going to make you happy